[Music]
in natural viagra news submitted by the
Tourism Board is that true yeah natural
way the oysters oysters I heard that
before - aphrodisiacs Indonesia wants to
make itself a tourist destination for
penis enlargement massages penis
enlargement massage they're inches and
you know your scrotum like later how far
back in your scrotum Oh like in there I
don't know in your scrotum how do you
bring it out body I guess massaging
watch it Lily be like oh sorry yeah so
this is a Vice article because of course
this would be a vice articles anybody
who's surprised raised their head that's
what I thought so
Indonesia is home to a lot of
alternative medicines and stuff like
that is pretty big there it's actually
one of the main kinds of medicine that's
available in the country and a lot of
people still use it pretty regularly so
Indonesia's Ministry of Health wants to
capitalize on that and they want to
declare penis enlargement massages known
as maca I wrote I'm probably saying that
wrong but you know y'all can offend all
of them now yeah all of them Mac air
ought to be a national app that has the
potential to attract medical tourists
from Broadbeach so because they say that
it's gonna be so popular obviously
because it's your two favorite things
penis enlargement and [ __ ] massages
that they can that they want to you know
offer it as a service that people you
know traveling from our bride and you
know how people do medical tourism you
know going to other places to get
surgeries done like we're talking about
in a previous video they can come here
to get a penis enlargement surgery but
to be on our not sorry it's not surgery
massages but honestly it kind of said it
sounds really sketch because the massage
is like you know that you know the whole
point the quartering thing the
quartering thing you know what you can
clean and they like scrape it across
your Chinese that's a quarter and they
would like to scrape you over and over I
know about the jar thing what the jar
there
yeah yeah because I guess they also
offer other massage services where they
rub a coin and against your skin with
menthol oil and stuff like that just
slightly damaged blood vessels and to
heal certain things that's how that holy
master was out bro yeah pulling out all
the toxins it works yeah so it sounds
like that would be something kind of
similar to this which scares the [ __ ]
out of me to be seeing anyone nobody
[ __ ] getting close to mine like dick
with a [ __ ] raping you with a piece
of metal to the point where you bruise
on your dick apparently yeah apparently
but you could get a bigger dick because
it's another practice solid put tron
come on girth wise or word length - I
vote no your flavor is yeah so I'm not
you time when you wish more because the
article is a little vague on how if
that's if the coining thing is supposed
to be used on your dick or not but the
way that it's phrased in the article at
least it sounds like that's how it's
exact sentence but it's yeah Toronto
also mentioned Carrick is a viable
source of medical tourism which is a
method of curing variety of ailments by
rubbing a coin against the skin of the
back with menthol oil and neat lines
slightly damaging blood vessels sure but
then the part that has to go to the
penis yeah because carol is the so
they're saying they're using that method
maybe did do it by your bladder you know
how you hit baby like oh okay so Mach
arrow is the penis massaging one and
then Kara
is this other that's the quarter one
yeah is the quarter one yeah they're too
close together
if idea of like something rubbing yeah
so like taking the coin out of the
situation I'm imagining someone going in
with that much force
oh my dick I don't know if I want that I
don't know what if the dudes like just
what it would've like he's know nothing
but showers and not like no nothing
realize they're never actually like
scrapes uh so pulling in the dick with
these
I tried this before guys what what shot
oh but that boat woman fell you're
saying before that he never even got
hard oh no he got like that flaccid hard
he never got hard hard yeah you never
like actually got a wreck she was like
oh and he was like you know what really
turns me on some coins out for anal you
know I found this special technique I
will massage you and make your penis
bigger but just I do this [ __ ] how
much you know about the names of all
these things cuz butter on tow is
actually the Minister of Health Japanese
man read the Indonesian article this
this guy this guy's okay so the Minister
of Health is the one saying like look we
use we use the coining method so imagine
how much we would get if we had you know
penis massage is that right so he was
just saying like look all the things
work yeah the massaging work it's not
what if you massage all the things not
necessary like coining your penis I'm
just curious
have there been people who've done it
and are there reviews there are no there
are no reviews here but five stars on
Yelp the Minister of Health does say
don't estimate Carol if we had a hundred
rooms and it takes 20 minutes per person
imagine how much revenue that would
generate there are many other cultural
gems that we've not exploited because we
take it for granted but to foreigners if
something intriguing and that's a direct
quote
he's like imagine how we can exploit
this stuff exact matter if it bros are
not yes it matters if it makes money
yeah hey you know I just want to see if
it works I mean you're providing a
service that promises that you'll grow
it's not cultural appropriation if you
take your own culture and don't be use
the [ __ ] out of it I guess so yeah it's
but it's funny because he's just like
look at all this money we're leaving on
the table Julia wants to know so she can
bring Nelson over there she's like hey
we're gonna go
no no no no Nelson doesn't need it but
also like who out of like out of the
people that we're gonna go in and do
this thing anyway how many of them are
really gonna be coming ahead of this and
being like yeah it didn't work you know
like I feel like all of them are kind of
like wink wink nudge nudge
I know what I'm trying to get out of
this kind of deal I showed my wife and
she measured it again and it didn't work
yeah they're not telling anybody they
didn't make like a parody infomercial
like that yeah it's like by a girl but
it channels and works I was depress with
my small penis then I went to Indonesia
yeah and now I'm depressed out of money
stuck with a small piece my penis is
long bruised up from a [ __ ] coin yeah
that doesn't sound like a fun time if
anything maybe that's their way of
covering up I say we're gonna offer a
happy ending service is what I'm trying
to get at is that I think this is just a
ploy for like hey look it's medicinal
like you need this for a medicinal for
legalized brothel yeah so I mean you
know that's that's all fair I mean I
guess like if you want to make the
argument of like yeah it's you know
we're gonna bring in income and stuff
and like you know do what you want as
long as everyone's an adult and they're
consenting and stuff but at the same
time it's like this sounds I kind of see
you know what I kind of wonder though
what the menthol part with Phil I was so
curious about where he was going
you know you know that feeling that you
get where you're like hard start heart
rate starts to increase do it right with
vapor rub just by good revenge's I with
the Chinese people already do
with themselves tire valve from yellow I
won the white one like Tiger Balm but
it's the white one with the old Goudas
on there yeah what about ours coin with
that and that deal relating this back to
a penis I just want it burns like after
a few hours you know yeah I hate the
smell of it and it's because like
growing up Asian do like Vietnamese it's
called yo sadden it's like is it the
green bottle oil yeah and it's the same
[ __ ] Ella it's like tiger balm I hate
this algae from me whatever I smell I'm
like old people my father's old people
with my [ __ ] good spare room the
longest time I couldn't figure out what
smell is I was like why did this smell
like old people and turns out with some
Chinese mothballs hid in the corner the
[ __ ] closet the whole house did it
get better after you took it out it's
still like kind of thing cause I was
being saying you know I'm repainting
that room just so I can cover the smell
because it's just like so bad remember
we walk through your house removing you
know I walked through the room and I was
like the guy lived in here this is where
he went to sleep this is where he woke
up in the room this is where he spent
most of his time that's where he coined
his dick [ __ ] like really like it
den-tits part of the [ __ ] like carpet
just blood splatter on the wall how
corny your dick is like yep that's why
the blood is over here I'm like I think
someone was murdered in here like no no
this guy was trying to kind of gain
another centimeter on that boy was
Indonesian mothered he you see I typed
in pants were all right he's showing it
off like would you guys ever go to like
another another country for like some
sort of medical term
sorry I'm like where's he gone your dick
rub not penis enlarger up in Japan
riding a horse I getting Blowfish right
well I in terms of something medicine
that's supposed to heal me and Western
medicine panic especially alternative
Esther I'm Canadian so I have medicine
up there I can just go north to get
medicine I'll turn you in your [ __ ]
free health care sorry you gotta not
believe in herbs like to a certain
extent but do I believe this black suit
that my mom cooked me will hew me no no
don't worry
oh yes the do I believe that the tree
bark that makes it taste like [ __ ] that
will probably not no I don't know I took
I took that bitter ass soup for three
months three whole months and I didn't
get any better and so my mom was like
alright we're gonna take you to our
family doctor and all like what is a
family doctor say is like get some
[ __ ] and I guess it was like
throughout the span of ten days went
through half way my mom saw all my
symptoms go away she's like cool we'll
save the other five for later would you
like cou we got the new medicine out
there if you if you guys have some
antibiotics finish it all the way
through I mean I don't but you should
use off yeah at the recommended dose
yeah that's how they develop superbugs
cuz then if you don't [ __ ] finish the
corazon it'll grow then it gets
resistant to it and then you'll get
really sick and then you'll spread it to
somebody like me and then I'll get
really sick and I won't have anything to
fix it with all so Brian what about the
mercury in the vaccine [ __ ] die alone
AIDS yeah full-blown amagai family got
it yeah don't count the guy it's okay
because because an NGO TV show said it
before we did so yeah well it's got AIDS
8:8 that's that's a reference to America
Oh with that to America
I thought that was a having a Q now L
see America because like they have an
entire thing like out Baldwin and all
them and they're singing about everybody
has AIDS and a big it doesn't matter
[Music]